you've got to decide whether you're a
wolf
or a sheep you know I have never I guess
played the bad guy before it's a gritty
kind of a feeling to it and and uh
you know yeah I had fun
it's been 20
since Denzel took his second Academy
Award for his performance in Training
Day you got today and today only to show
me who and What You're Made Of it's a
story about a Cop who was in some bad
circumstances
who puts another cop in a compromised
position E.T was with Denzel the day he
learned about his nomination which at
the time was his fifth I felt pretty
good people were saying it looked good
for me but still
you get nervous heading into show night
Denzel was anything but stressed I
watched the basketball game we went to
church I came home and watched the game
that's it that's all right that's her
clothes I'm ready at five minutes before
I got dressed Julia Roberts Denzel's
good friend and Pelican Brief co-star
had the honor of announcing his category
and I thank the academy for
saying to me that on this given night I
was the best that I could be
[Applause]
as an actor I truly feel as though he
he kind of embodies everything that we
all Inspire to be and he fulfills every
debt he offers to pay and he carried me
off the stage too Julia said you
actually picked her up and her feet were
dangling off the stairs yeah she's crazy
Julia's crazy she was happier than me
Denzel told us playing the bad guy for a
change might have worked in his favor I
think it you know had I played another I
don't know I don't know another hero or
real person I I think that playing this
role did kind of shock people a little
bit and showed them that I could do
other things I don't do any role for
that reason certain roles have a certain
you know Vibe about them like a Malcolm
X or even the hurricane definitely in
that training day but uh you know turned
out well Denzel also took a moment to
reflect on his first Oscar win in 1990
when he nabbed best supporting actor for
the Civil War epic Glory
oh you don't like that do you
well what we gonna do about it you know
the first time around is just really the
one when you go crazy because it's it's
just you know all your life up to that
moment it was like I was stunned like I
wasn't sure if I really won or
I just thought maybe I had passed out
this time around it's a different kind
of feeling you know like I said relief
is a big part of it too but it's just an
honor and and I accept it with Grace and
humility this year Denzel extended his
record as the most nominated black actor
in Oscar's history his nod for the
tragedy of Macbeth makes 10 over the
course of his career
let me see him and it marks nearly two
decades since beating King Richard star
Will Smith in the best actor category
will was nominated for Ali in the same
season Training Day came out now the two
are facing off again how does that full
circle moment feel and does it feel
different this time around I just hope
we're going to need a tiebreaker
[Music]
thank you